un braqueur mais double carburateur vous
vous en moquez peut-être nous n'en
parlerons pas pour découvrir cette
nouvelle alfa romeo l'alfasud sprint
[Musique]
c'est un coupé mais avec portes arrière
donnant accès à un très grand coffre
plus de 300 litres
[Musique]
et
signe des temps alfa romeo s'adapte à
l'évolution du marché et le caractère
purement sportif s'estompe légèrement
devant les impératifs de confort et
d'habitabilité
mais cette sprint ne renie pas ses
origines et le styliste giugiaro signe
encore une oeuvre superbe
même si certains lui reprochent quelques
airs de déjà vu
ouais
à
[Musique]
et en conservant l'empattement d'origine
de la berline le coupé sprint offre
réellement 4e place
[Musique]
oh
à noter le volant réglable en hauteur
et bien sûr la fameuse boîte 5 vitesses
[Musique]
dans cette période d'automobiles
banalisée il est hélas de plus en plus
rares de saluer une véritable auto
passionnante et attaché manifestement
l'alfasud sprint a beaucoup de races
très sûre confortable et silencieuse
elle a gagné un peu de brio car sa
cylindrée portée à 1286 centimètres
cubes lui permet d'annoncer 67 chevaux
réel et 165 km heure
regrettons simplement un équipement
pneumatiques d'une médiocrité certaines
quelques privilégiés auront la chance
d'obtenir cette alfasud sprint dans les
prochaines semaines moyennant 35 mille
francs
[Musique]